president donald trump has been
impeached again
making him the only president in history
to be impeached
two times and in fact uh this has been a
presidency
rife with firsts but they're all
pretty bad and we're going to talk about
that in a subsequent segment but
yes donald trump becoming the first
president to be impeached twice
the house this time voting on just a
single charge
citing trump's role in inciting
that mob that violently went to the
capitol on january 6th and donald trump
now
will face a senate trial that could
disqualify him from future office
although that senate trial
by every indication isn't going to
happen until joe biden assumes the
presidency
10 republicans joined democrats
in the house of representatives in
voting
yesterday for the impeachment of donald
trump
this was now a capital much more
militarized much more fortified
by law enforcement and military uh as a
result
of what took place on january 6th let's
go
to the moment that it happened nancy
pelosi announcing the results
for the second time during donald
trump's presidency that indeed the
president has been impeached
on this vote the eyes are 232
the nays are 197
the resolution is adopted without
objection the motion to reconsider is
laid upon the
table congratulations
so going forward when we say the trump
impeachment
we are going to need to clarify which of
the two
trump impeachments we are referring to
and notably different
this time versus the house vote
about a year ago a little more than a
year ago in impeaching donald trump the
first time
10 republicans joining the democrats
congressman
catco liz cheney kinzinger upton
herrera butler new house mayor
gonzalez rice and valedao
joining the democratic party i don't
think that these republicans are
particularly valiant or brave although
we will talk on the bonus show today
about how liz cheney
is facing calls to resign because she
voted
for the impeachment of donald trump can
you imagine
resign because you
did the thing that is your
responsibility and duty to do as a
member of the house of representatives
very backwards
very backwards calls for resignation we
are hearing uh
from republicans and this is going to be
yet another stain
on donald trump's legacy only one week
before
leaving office to the day and um
we are i mean listen this this is we
talk
we've talked a lot over the last four
years
as we've fallen further and further down
in terms of global respectability
and as the shame has grown and the
humiliation has grown we've talked about
what will it take to get back to where
we were and for many of us where we were
wasn't that great i mean okay
diplomatically the united states was
more respected around the world under
barack obama and previous presidencies
but
we still were falling behind in dealing
with climate we still weren't getting
health care to everybody
even as one of the richest countries in
the world we still had hunger we still
had unemployment you know it
we we were far better off than we are
now
far more respected but we still had
serious problems to solve
and um we cannot it is unreasonable
to expect that after this level of
global shame
and domestic shame just because the
trump is don't feel ashamed doesn't mean
it's not significant shame it took four
years for this to culminate in donald
trump's second impeachment and this
riotous mob that he incited
it's going to take more than six months
to make significant headway in
in getting out of it and hopefully our
historical allies
uh will will forgive us that's really
the question
and there is going to be a lot of work
digging out from this
even many republicans in house speeches
yesterday in the anticipation of this
vote
including representative kevin mccarthy
conceding
that yes donald trump was to blame
for what happened at the capitol last
week
um but many continuing to insist that
despite that
it is not impeachable so
we are all of course disappointed that
there are unlikely to be greater
consequences for
donald trump if things go incredibly
well
and the senate votes to convict when
they likely
um in february march
april we don't know convene for the
impeachment trial of trump
uh if they were to convict it is uh
a possibility that trump will face the
consequence of not being able to run
again
but we all wish there had been more
consequences and
i i think maybe the biggest takeaway is
were it not for you getting out and
voting in 2018 to take that majority
away in the house of representatives
from republicans
were it not for you voting in 2020 to
remove donald trump
and to give democrats a senate majority
we wouldn't even be seeing
a lot of what we've seen the first
impeachment wouldn't have happened were
it not for the 2018 vote
the second impeachment i mean we'd be
dealing with a different situation
let's put it that way were it not for
taking the white house and the senate
uh in in november and in the runoff
elections in georgia in january so there
are
successes here uh but we all wish that
there had been more consequences
and earlier on for what has been
arguably the most atrocious presidency
in modern political history one of our
sponsors is
four sigmatic the company best known for
their delicious
mushroom coffee four sigmatics mushroom
coffee is
organic fair trade single origin arabica
coffee
with both lion's mane and chaga
mushrooms chaga mushrooms have actually
been shown to have potential in
supporting the immune system in
peer-reviewed studies
i've been drinking four sigmatic coffee
a lot lately it actually doesn't taste
anything like mushrooms it just tastes
like any
delicious coffee but it's really easy on
my stomach doesn't give me any jittery
feeling
or a midday crash and they have over 20
000 five-star reviews and best of all
if you don't love it you'll get 100
percent of your money back
because they stand behind their product
you've got nothing to lose by giving it
a try
four sigmatic is giving my audience up
to forty percent off
and free shipping when you go to four
sigmatic dot com slash pacman the link
is right underneath this video